my husband made breakfast for the
whole family this morning
which is another way of saying
my husband made a mess
so we have a system in my house where
the person who cooks
doesn't have to do the dishes
even though this rule kinda backfires on me
cause I was always raised to clean up as I go
but I digress and if you know me
you know I dedicate a ridiculous amount of hours each week
just trying to stay on top of the housework
and I'm always looking for ways to make it quicker
more effective and less tedious if I'm honest
and about halfway through last year
I stumbled across these Finish Ultimate Plus
dishwashing tablets
and honestly they're worth the hype
because Finish Ultimate Plus is so
effective at cleaning my dishes
I don't even need to pre rinse them anymore
if you're anything like me
you'll know what a game changer that is
I always get asked on my cleantoks what this little thing is
it's a dishwasher freshener
it smells really good and it lasts for ages
and I popped it in along with my
Finish Rinse Aid and dishwashing tablet
and after my dishwasher was out here doing the most
it's time for the moment of truth to see how
Finish dealt with my dirty dishes
and I'm not even surprised that there is no trace of the
hard crusty egg yolk or baked on chocolate oats
the glassware is sparkling and the stainless steel is so shiny
it's a big yes from me